[Music]
[Applause]
Tyrese halberton of my Pacers will join
us coming up 12th overall pick by the
kings in the 2020 draft he became an
overnight sensation after a few years in
the playin tournament the inseason
tournament I was ahead of the game with
Tyrese halberton playing with Sacramento
yes I was that guy watching coming in
and talking to Marvin I'd say man Tyrese
halberton can play and Marvin goes he
can play but nobody's going to see him I
said no no this is the year Sacramento
they're going to make the playoffs and
uh they had a good team now he goes to
the Pacers and that became more about
sabonis going to the Kings than I did I
think Tyrese Alberton going to the
Pacers but had the moment there with
Dame Dame Lillard with uh the game
against Milwaukee so a lot of good stuff
there and Tyrese Halbert and the Pacers
point guard joining us on the program
thanks for joining us how many
scholarship offers did you have coming
out of high school oh that's a good
question uh probably like 15 20 like
mid- major schools but in terms of high
major I'd probably only say like four or
five who were
they uh Nebraska Iowa
State we consider Cincinnati High major
now yeah right 12 yeah uh Minnesota
okay and Michigan wanted me they said if
I visited I would have an offer but I
didn't go on the visit so those are
really like the five schools okay when
do you get a chip on your
shoulder uh my whole life really I mean
I think I think in high
school I played I grew up playing with
Tyler hero we grew up playing Au
together and then uh while everybody was
getting better I kind of leveled out and
they kind of went they went to a
different Au program which was like the
better program and I and I kind of got
left behind so I stayed and um that that
probably is when it started and it's
kind of just Amplified since then and
you hold that against Tyler hero even to
this day I don't hold that against him
we're we're we're we're cool now oh okay
I mean if you say you know you hate
Tyler hero that's fine I mean I don't oh
no okay all right fair enough uh how do
you give up 151 point I don't know but
we figured it out I guess we've done it
I think that's the second time we've
done it
first time we did it we won we won the
first time we did it but yeah last night
last night was a rough one okay did you
get yelled at yet um yes yes multiple
times but we haven't started our we
haven't started our day yet in terms of
practice and stuff so I'm sure sure we
got more coming up here soon it feels
like this has been a coming out party
for you this year even though you played
well in sacr like people are just
finding out who you are nationally does
it feel that way for sure for sure and
that's just because I was never on
national TV like I'd have my first
national TV game until I think my until
my second year or the end of my second
year because we played Brooklyn and then
I didn't play on TNT until this year so
I mean I haven't people haven't just
never seen me play for the most part
like a casual fan do you get mistaken
for anybody on the streets no not in
Indie these days I think people for the
most part know okay yeah but you're
wearing your full uniform when you go
out that's the weird thing though when
you go out right no never
never actually had Smoothie King the
other day a dude the Ser it was like a
16-year- old kid he said you know you
look a lot like Tyrese hbert does
anybody ever tell you that I was like I
get that all the
time all right take me back to the game
against
Milwaukee now when you did you decide to
do the Dame time to
Dame uh in the moment I never this
wasn't something I cooked up before it
was just a in the- moment thing but how
did he take that or how did you think he
was going to take that um I didn't
really know I didn't really know I
thought he actually took it um a lot
better than a lot of people would I
thought his response was I thought the
question was presented really well in
media and I thought he responded really
well um and uh yeah I think at the end
of the day it's respect and and and I
have a lot of admiration for him part of
the reason I wear zero is because of
Damen Lillard like I was been a fan for
the majority of my life so uh it's a
respect thing at the end of the day uh
but it's just competing all right when
did you know there was a basketball
problem with the
Bucks bask
oh when did I know I knew okay so let
you know Giannis goes for you know the
franchise record points you have a
teammate Oscar schwebe who got his first
point um yeah so when did did you
realize that there was a real issue here
going on be uh behind the scenes after
the game I did not realize that there
was anything with the ball until Giannis
was running to our locker room I had no
idea that anything was I they were it
was a problem that guys did not Shake we
didn't shake hands after the game uh but
that's normal that happens in the NBA
all the time uh but then when I saw him
run to the locker room I like why is he
doing that and then somebody said
something about the ball and I was like
oh okay
but everybody every rookie who scores
gets a
basketball yeah the Pacers organization
if a rookie scores his first point then
he gets the B then he gets the ball but
just to clarify we did not have the game
basketball just so everybody's aware I
know that that's been talked about a
million times in the world but we did
you have the backup basketball for Oscar
correct yes we do yes we do okay did you
tell Giannis and if you haven't you get
to talk to him what you know in a week
or so uh like uh what after New Year's I
think you guys are New Year's Day you
guys are playing yeah we play yeah we
play them New Year's Day um I'm pretty
sure he's very aware of it at this point
I'm pretty sure he was aware of it very
shortly after going to the locker room
as well uh but I just don't think he
wanted to they they didn't want to admit
to that but what was he gonna do Tyrese
when if he came into the locker room
what was going to happen you know that's
a question for him I I really don't know
what the plan was I don't know if there
was much of a plan I think it was just
uh built up a lot of testosterone going
on a lot of frustration going on I think
he's the Pacers point guard All-Star
Tyrese halberton joining us on the
program Lakers celebrated with the
inseason
banner would you guys have done the same
thing I suggested a parade I would have
done a parade the Pacers
absolutely 100 I would have been down
for whatever I mean we don't we don't
have any B we don't have a championship
banners in the arena P have never W NBA
championship so um I would have been all
for the banner no question do you think
the Lakers should have raised the banner
given that it's the Lakers I I you know
I think at the end of the day I think
that that helps build up the legitimacy
of the tournament and that's what the
league is trying to do with it they want
it to be something that people are
competing for every year and I think the
fact that the most storied organization
won it and hung it up I mean SEC maybe
first or second whatever your opinion is
uh the fact that they hung it up I think
that uh that that brings more legitimacy
to the tournament for sure whose poster
did you have on your wall growing up uh
a lot of LeBron I had LeBron Fathead
like the back in the day had heads I had
uh T-Mac on the wall Magic on the wall
uh that was for the most part those guys
okay what what's that like first time
you're out there with LeBron and he's
guarding you or you're guarding him oh I
was like what's going it was like a it
was like a uh I felt like like Mike I
felt like Kelvin Cambridge and like Mike
like it was I felt like that every I
felt like that every game like my first
ever preseason game I got switched on to
Carmelo and I was like what is going on
right now like that's what the NBA like
I really like my first year for the
majority of my first year I just felt
like a kid in the candy store it was
just unbelievable feeling but what was
that welcome to the NBA
moment oh I don't know if anything
specific you know actually we played on
I think it was New Year's New Year's Eve
we played the rockets and I tried to
dunk on John Wall and he blocked it and
I fell on my back and I went to the ER
and the doctor told me that my injuries
were consistent with those of a car
crash and I was like yeah the NBA is a
different world when I knew yeah well if
you can't dunk on John Wall you're
probably not going to go in there
against Rudy goar and some guys yeah
yeah you know I in my head when I was
going to dunk it I was like
this is going to be cool back home like
I if I dunk on John Wall like everybody
we love John Wall growing up so I was
like this would be cool but he had other
plans H do you are you aware of your
coach's playing career uh I am aware I
am aware okay so you're aware of maybe
your dad tell you about Rick
carile uh no definitely did not I didn't
know I didn't know uh his like career
path until I got here and got to talk to
him more about it and pick his brain and
stuff does he shoot at all anymore
uh I'm trying I really don't know if
I've ever seen him shoot a jumper I
don't know if I ever have I've seen him
when he's working with guys on shooting
and he does the form thing and he holds
the ball but I don't know if I've ever
seen him actually take a jumper okay who
taught you how to
shoot uh I think myself I think
naturally I just over time my form has
just progressed but it started with me
just in the park learning how to shoot
doing it myself and as I got older and
working with uh other coaches and stuff
and getting strong it just became about
taking the dip out of my shot but
keeping it the same at the top but you
there's a little bit of a Twist at the
end right yeah yeah yeah I mean it's not
a normal shot now this coming from a guy
who gave shooting tips to Ray Allen one
time when he came into my my Dojo here
my man so I uh which is embarrassing it
might sound embarrassing but I I really
was believing what I was saying to Ry he
had the ball on the palm of his hand and
I said Ray you got to have it there has
to be a little bit of space there and
Ray could have been that much better
Tyrese I mean imagine if he had listened
to me years ago and if you want a
session free of charge you can ask Co
coach Carlile um I know what I'm doing
he calls me the radio broadcasting
version of Larry Bird so um wow yeah so
I can help if you need it right now you
seem to be doing okay but if you ever
get in that slump where you go damn what
did that guy say and no I can be there
I'm a little bit I'm in a little bit of
a stump right now
so well no you need to learn to play
defense you gave up 151 points last
night I hope you guys get yelled at at
practice today oh don't worry I'm sure
we will hey congrats happy for you yeah
and thanks for joining us yes of course
thanks for having me that's Tyrese
Halbert he is doing his a holiday hoopla
this afternoon where he provides 30 um
youth from Cafe this is the um Community
Alliance Far East Side the opportunity
for dinner and uh $300 shopping spre at
a local sporting goods store as well
that's good stuff